52 657 I have eyes on the
vehicle what's your
location natural brid training
station natural brid tring
[Music]
station 67 which direction are you going
I'm about natural briding good
fell
good vehicle's pulling
over p
over step out of the
vehicle what's the license place
Ed Adam 5 linol 2 William step out of
the vehicle I'm not going to tell you
again get out of the
vehicle it's in for I got got War go
point back up turn around and back up
calm down it's not even that serious bro
calm down
bro what's going
on
you all right little man you
good yeah my son in that car child is in
the car the one the saying he's the
father
theore with the car supposed to be stol
for Quick Trip yeah s on quick trip huh
there's the accident s on Quick
Trip
gra my out of that
car come here kiddo you're not in
trouble I just want to get you away from
this car
okay come
here
what the fuck is all this about
bro they'll explain it to
you you all right you
heard
okay he fled from me too so okay he F
the you yeah he see me I turned around
he he took off he almost hit two other
cars bud what's your
[Music]
the is everybody in
C
releas how are you doing
buddy what's your
name I'm going to get you in my car
okay I'm going to put him my come on
you're going to follow me my car right
here
okay hey hey how's it going so he fled
from you so they were coming that way
and they were coming this way so I
flipped my lights on and he just took
off almost hit two other vehicles as
well what is it
so
that already
there yeah he pulled over right
here I was on Wing about
something well I heard it and then when
they said handling a natural bridge I
just stayed right
there
go that's why he stopped I an accident
at 16
and suspect
what
6 I got you what do you
want are you guys going to take them in
or yeah I mean we can we can take them
are you down there
yeah if
you're if yall are going to your
department I can transport them I
got behind
break yeah if you don't mind you
transport for us that'd be sick yeah and
then I'll get dogs this
fuck ahead
back
so what's what's the situation with
him it's a disagreement I mean either
way we got a
felony kid endanger child endanger yeah
we're good on everything what's up D
that was few minutes away so yeah you
guys didn't hear
anything by 26 go your
subject
dis col if you're good brother I'm going
to head out I just wanted to make sure
this is pretty cut clear and dry
so
6 it's been the fan
lately I'm going to transport this
suspect to s
for so
can you call H and have
resp we can just have him transport
here hey I'm going to have you transport
him back to the station
he's in my car you want to put your cups
on going on man well you're going to be
going to jail for a couple felonies for
where felony fleeing for one fleeing
from who and child I I didn't flee from
nobody bro come on bro off I swear to
God I I pull right over for you I never
fle from you offic
I didn't in front from you bro I didn't
flee from you this isn't even my charges
this is s's charges I pull right over on
well right over for you I didn't flee
from you what
the and that's my stepson what do you
mean here's the thing Hey listen listen
you want to take cuffs off
you I'm going take the Cuffs off you for
my arm okay
Dam bro I didn't flee from you bro and
that's honest God TR bro if I F from you
why would I flee from you with my son in
the car man come on bro what I look like
man I didn't flee from you bro you
didn't hit your lights until right when
I got over there right by the startop
and I pulled over for you you're going
to have all the time talking we get back
to char bullshit bro s s is the one
taking you in
custody they can explain
everything man this
bro how do you how do you like it over
there
come you do I have an interview this
week